bonjour nous vous proposons de suivre ce
matin sur l'antenne de public sénat à
une audition du ministre de l'industrie
eric besson sur l'aménagement numérique
du territoire
une audition devant la commission de
l'économie du sénat la haute assemblée
va en effet bientôt examiné en seconde
lecture ce sera la mi février une
proposition de loi du sénateur centriste
hervé maurey qui porte justement sur
l'amélioration de la couverture
numérique à haut débit alors selon le
constat dressé dans son rapport par le
sénateur hervé maurey
eh bien la france a pris beaucoup de
retard dans ce domaine beaucoup de
retard par rapport à la planification
prévu nicolas sarkozy avait en effet
affiché une couverture à 100 % à haut
débit d'ici 2025 on est aujourd'hui très
très loin de cet objectif puisque
seulement 1 millions des foyers français
sont possiblement raccordables à la
fibre et seulement cinq cent mille
foyers sont effectivement abonnés à la
filme donc très très loin de l'objectif
on va donc suivre cette audition d'eric
besson pour voir un petit peu quelles
sont les solutions qui vont être
apportées dans les prochaines semaines
par le gouvernement
très bonne audition à toussaint je vous
rappelle dans quel cadre ont reçu un
monsieur eric besson s'agit de la
proposition le roi mort est pour lequel
la commission a nommé monsieur hervé
maurey comme rapporteur je vous rappelle
aussi que monsieur me morais avait déjà
commis un rapport sur l'aménagement
numérique du territoire qui avait été
adoptée à l'unanimité de notre
commission le 6 juillet 2011
ce rapport indiquait que la situation en
matière de déploiement des réseaux
numériques fixes comme mobiles étaient
loin d'être satisfaisante avec notamment
des parties entières du territoire non
desservis mais on en reparlera jeu pas
en faire et ils seront est très critique
à l'égard du programme national de très
haut débit le fameux pnt hd
ce rapport a débouché donc à la mi
novembre 2011 sur une proposition de loi
cosignée par messieurs le roi est mort
est ils ont assuré l'aménagement
numérique du territoire
je vais pas revenir sur les articles le
rapporteur va sans doute nous en parler
plus longuement et en connaissance de
cause mieux mois mais simplement vous
rappeler les le cheminement
c'est de la commission de l'économie a
déjà auditionné monsieur jean luc
silicani président de l'arcep le 30
novembre 2011
d'ailleurs à ce sujet nous avons
également auditionné monsieur bruno
lasserre président de l'autorité de la
concurrence le 18 janvier dernier avec
les problèmes qui ont été évoqués sur
les interventions des collectivités
territoriales et vous êtes auditionné
monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui pour
vous entendre sur 7 sur ce projet de loi
je rappelle que vous étiez déjà
intervenu je vais sujet lors du débat en
séance publique sur le rapport
d'information et ceci le 12 octobre 2011
donc monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole
et ensuite je les donnerai évidemment en
priorité aux rapporteurs
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
veux saluer le rapporteur hervé moore et
le sénateur philippe leroy co auteur de
ce texte la mise et messieurs les les
sénateurs le déploiement des réseaux
numériques constitue un enjeu majeur
pour la compétitivité de notre économie
et l'attractivité de nos territoires
l'accès à internet haut débit fixe et
mobile est devenu une condition
d'intégration dans notre société notre
démocratie notre économie et notre
culture comme l'eau ou l'électricité
il est devenu ce que les économistes
appellent une commodité essentielle et
remémorer et philippe leroy ont déposé
vous l'avez rappelé une proposition de
loi le 17 novembre 2011 visant à assurer
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
cette proposition se réfère à un
objectif de première importance celui
d'un déploiement équilibré des réseaux
dans nos territoires pour aborder la
discussion de cette proposition de loi
je crois qu'il faut d'abord rappeler le
contexte dans lequel elle entend
s'inscrire
d'abord je veux rappeler que la france
est très bien placé en matière de
numérique
ce secteur a créé sept cent mille
emplois nets en 15 ans d'ici à 2015
les experts estiment que 450 mille
emplois supplémentaires seront créés
très peu de pays dans le monde à part
évidemment les états unis ont réussi à
développer des entreprises comme
dailymotion priceminister ou deezer qui
sont devenus des géants mondiaux de
l'internet
la france compte aussi des géants des
services informatiques
je ne cite que de nom capgemini et atos
origin qui entre qui remportent des
marchés partout dans le monde
notre industrie du logiciel je prends
cet autre exemple compte des références
mondiales
je pense à cegid à dassault systèmes ou
ingénico enfin dernier exemple notre
industrie du jeu
vidéo est la plus performante au monde
avec le numéro un mondial
vivendi games le numéro quatre mondial
ubisoft est le numéro un le numéro un
mondial des accessoires pour jeux
big ben depuis cinq ans le gouvernement
a accompli des efforts je crois
réellement sans précédent pour
développer ce secteur
jamais sans doute une politique aussi
ambitieuse n'avait été engagé en faveur
du numérique
elle se traduit tout d'abord par un
soutien aux usages
rien ne sert d'installer ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler maintenant des tuyaux
s'il n'y a pas de contenus et de
services pour nos concitoyens et pour
nos entreprises
le gouvernement consacre 2 5 milliards
d'euros des investissements d'avenir au
développement des nouveaux usages
numérisation des contenus culturels
services mobiles sans contact et
éducation sont des exemples parmi
d'autres d'innovation développées en
partenariat entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
cette politique se traduit ensuite par
un soutien puissant au début au
déploiement des réseaux grâce au plan
france numérique 2012
nous sommes dotés d'un des réseaux
numériques les plus performants et les
plus étendus en europe
je rappelle rapidement et pourtant cet
essentiel mais je vais être que rapide
sur ce point que s'agissant de la
télévision numérique terrestre
nous avons réussi en moins de quatre ans
l'une des principales révolution
audiovisuelle depuis le passage à la
télévision couleur 100 % de la
population reçoit désormais la
télévision numérique terrestre ou
satellitaires l'ensemble des français
reçoit désormais 19 chaînes gratuites en
qualité numérique pour l'image et pour
le son six nouvelles chaînes en haute
définition complèteront prochainement
cette offre c'est un succès majeur pour
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
agissant des réseaux mobiles ce sont 99
8 % des français qui bénéficie d'une
couverture en téléphonie mobile le taux
de pénétration à dépasser les 100%
pour autant je le sais et si je ne le
savais pas et vous me le rappeler
régulièrement mais il se trouve par
ailleurs que je le sais il reste comme
dans tous les pays du monde des zones
blanches pas seulement dans les zones
rurales ou semi rural même dans les
grandes villes on pourrait même dire
même à paris on trouve encore des zones
où la couverture n'est pas satisfaisante
c'est pourquoi nous poursuivons nos
efforts pour à parachever cette
couverture d'abord nous mettons en
oeuvre depuis 2003 le programme dit
jaune blanche avec la coopération des
opérateurs et des collectivités
il a permis ce programme l'installation
d'environ 2000 antennes relais couvrant
plus de 3000 centre bourg
l'investissement engagé par les
opérateurs par l'état et par les
collectivités territoriales dépasse déjà
600 millions d'euros
deuxièmement nous veillons à faire
appliquer les obligations de couverture
du territoire en technologie dite 3g
c'est à dire en haut débit mobile depuis
la fin de l'année 2011
les opérateurs doivent avoir couvert 98%
de la population ce qui est largement
supérieur à la moyenne européenne qui
est vous le savez je le rappelle de
l'ordre de 90%
troisièmement nous avons attribué les
meilleures fréquences jamais affecté aux
télécommunications dans l'histoire de
notre pays celle du dividende numérique
conformément à la loi relative à la
lutte contre la fracture numérique
nous avons retenu les critères les plus
favorables à l'aménagement du territoire
jamais mise en oeuvre est incertain un
certain nombre d'entre vous ici présent
il y avait contribué et avaient
manifesté au moment de cette adoption
votre vigilance
je vais insister sur ce point en effet
99 26% de la population
devra devront être couverts par
l'ensemble des opérateurs dans un délai
de quinze ans pour la première fois une
obligation de couverture départementale
a été fixé égal à 90% de la population
dans un délai de quinze ans les
opérateurs de cadre de l'appel à
candidatures sont allés encore plus loin
en s'engageant à couvrir 95% de la
population de chaque département pour la
première fois également une zone de
couverture dite prioritaire a été
définie représentant 18% de la
population mais 60% de nos territoires
autrement dit nos territoires les moins
denses et les plus ruraux la 4g sera
ainsi je veux y assister pardonnez-moi
mais la 4g sera ainsi le premier réseau
à être déployés simultanément dans les
villes et dans les campagnes
ça ne nous était jamais arrivé avec
l'attribution des licences 4g
la france est l'une des premières
nations au monde avec la suède peut être
l'allemagne avec les etats-unis a lancé
le très haut débit mobile
par ailleurs conformément à l'article 5
de votre proposition de loi et comme je
m'y étais engagé nous avons lancé le
groupe de travail sur la couverture
mobile
ce groupe de travail réunira état
collectivités locales opérateurs et
associations de consommateurs les
parlementaires y participeront ce groupe
de travail a pour objectif de préparer
un nouveau programme jaunes blanches et
de clarifier les critères appliqués pour
évaluer la couverture du territoire
parce qu'il faut qu'on sorte un jour de
ce débat que nous avons en permanence
sur ce qui est couvert partiellement
couverts moyennement couvert avec chacun
qui de bonne foi et je pourrai apporter
mon propre témoignage dit oui mais
lorsque je me retrouve dans telle ville
je suis couvert à tel endroit je ne suis
plus à tel autre et donc je considère
que ce n'est pas couvert
clarifions ça et éventuellement prenons
des dispositions afférentes
les travaux techniques ont déjà démarré
et la réunion de lancement officielle se
déroulera le 8 février prochain
à cet égard je veux vous dire
sincèrement que l'article 6 de cette
proposition de loi me paraît
problématique
il crée en effet de nouvelles
obligations de couverture du territoire
pour les opérateurs titulaires des
licences
je veux vous alerter mais je sais que
vous en êtes conscient sur un point
modifier les obligations des licences
engage évidemment la responsabilité de
l'état en effet l'état a vendu des
licences a sorti c'est une évidence
d'obligations précise en matière de
couverture du territoire les modifier
change donc nécessairement la valeur de
ces licences et les prix auxquels elles
ont été vendues seront donc contesté par
les opérateurs
et si l'état doit rembourser une partie
des licences de la téléphonie mobile
je crois et je crains qu'il soit
difficile aux rapporteurs et le sénateur
ici présent de dire comment trouver les
crédits correspondants
de plus cela ne semble pas s'inscrire je
le dis aussi directement dans une
démarche de bonne gestion des deniers
publics par ce qui concerne les réseaux
fixes nous avons mis en place un
programme national très haut débit très
ambitieux il repose sur quatre piliers
le premier pilier
ce sont les investissements privés et la
mutualisation
le gouvernement a défini le cadre
réglementaire de la mutualisation des
réseaux avec la loi de modernisation de
l'économie du 4 août 2008 et ses décrets
d'application du 15 janvier 2009 mais
aussi les arrêtés du 15 janvier 2010 et
du 10 janvier 2011 homologuant des
décisions de l'arcep
grâce à ce cadre les opérateurs se sont
engagés à couvrir 57% de la population
en fibre optique dans les dix prochaines
années
alors j'ai entendu je connais vos
interrogations sur ce point et certains
d'entre vous n'aviez interpellé sur ce
sujet
je vous ai dit je veux redire devant
votre commission que le gouvernement
veillera tous les ans à ce que les
engagements soient respectés
ainsi et conformément au calendrier que
je vous avais annoncé nous allons
interroger à la fin du moins avec rené
ricol le commissaire général à
l'investissement
l'ensemble des opérateurs sur
l'avancement de leur déploiement et le
gouvernement sera ferme sur le respect
des engagements de déploiement dès la
première année
être ferme et ça veut dire quoi
et pour être très clair parce que
évidemment il s'agit d'un point
essentiel si l'engagement
d'investissement se révéler non
respectés si leurs engagements
d'investissement n'était pas respectée
la zone d'investissement privé seraient
réduites pour laisser la place aux
projets des collectivités ne faut pas
croire qu'il s'agit là d'une menace
prise à la légère par les opérateurs
être propriétaire d'un réseau et le
coeur du modèle économique de plusieurs
opérateurs quand vous le savez 2e pilier
le soutien aux initiatives publiques les
initiatives publiques seront soutenus
par tout une initiative privée est
absente
nous avons ouvert vous le savez le 27
juillet 2011
un guichet de 900 millions d'euros pour
aider les projets des collectivités
territoriales le programme national très
haut débit a été validé par l'arcep le
18 février 2010 par l'autorité de la
concurrence
17 mars 2010 et par la commission
européenne le 19 octobre 2011
il s'agit faut que chacun en ait
conscience du premier programme public
de soutien au très haut débit en europe
il constitue désormais une référence
pour les autres états membres la
commission européenne a apporté son
soutien à la démarche française reposant
sur la complémentarité entre
investissements publics et
investissements privés
le dispositif mis en place par le
gouvernement donne aujourd'hui ses
premiers résultats
les aides à cinq premiers projets
départementaux viennent d'être il ya
quelques jours vous le savez engagé pour
un montant de 53 millions d'euros
il s'agit de la manche de l'allier du
cantal de la haute loire et du puy de
dôme non je vous annonce que le comité
des réseaux d'initiative publique qui se
réunira le 2 février prochain examinera
les demandes l'aide de trois nouveaux
départements
l'objectif de 20 départements soutenue
d'ici à la fin de cette année me semble
donc raisonnable est atteignable si je
puis hier afin de suivre la mise en
oeuvre de ces projets nous avons mis en
place des commissions régionales pour
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
qui réunissent vous le savez vous y
participez collectivités et opérateurs
sous l'égide des préfets les services de
l'état qu'il s'agisse des services
centraux ou des services déconcentrés
sont entièrement mobilisés pour
accompagner les collectivités dans la
mise en place de leurs schémas
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
79 départements ou régions ont d'ores et
déjà adopté un tel schéma afin de
faciliter la mise en place des projets
des collectivités locales le
gouvernement a préparé par ailleurs une
nouvelle version du décret sur la
connaissance des réseaux
ce texte est je le sais très importantes
pour les collectivités car il leur
permet de recueillir les informations
sur les réseaux déployés par les
opérateurs
je vous indique que le nouveau décret
est encore plus ambitieux que ne l'était
le précédent dès le 1er janvier 2014
toutes les données devront être fournis
aux collectivités sur simple demande
gratuitement et sous format vectoriel
c'est à dire le meilleur format possible
pour planifier le déploiement d'un
réseau
nous n'attendons plus que l'avis de la
commission consultative à l'élaboration
des normes pour adopter ce nouveau
décret
le troisième pilier c'est la
mobilisation des promoteurs et des
constructeurs de logements neufs
le gouvernement a mis en place une
obligation d'équipement en fibre optique
des immeubles collectifs neufs
le décret d'application et l'arrêté ont
été publiés le 14 et le 16 décembre 2011
à partir du 1er avril 2012 deux cent
mille logements neufs seront ainsi
équipés
chaque année par les promoteurs
quatrième pilier le développement d'une
offre spécifique de très haut débit pour
les zones les plus reculées de notre
territoire
difficilement accessibles par la fibre
optique 40 millions d'euros
d'investissements ont été engagés pour
développer une nouvelle offre de très
haut débit par satellite s'agit de
recherche et développement c c 40
millions cet engagement permettra de
dépasser les performances du satellite
ka sat qui offrent d'ores et déjà dit
megabit par seconde sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire
j'en viens à présent très concrètement à
la lumière de ce contexte que j'ai
essayé de vous présenter à la
proposition de loi le deuxième alinéa de
l'article 2 rend obligatoire pour les
collectivités territoriales les
l'auberge l'élaboration de schémas
directeurs territoriaux d'aménagement
numérique
les esses dtn c'est intéressant et cela
pourrait même accélérer la démarche en
cours d'élaboration des schémas mais
vous êtes mieux à même que moi que nous
de juger de son acceptation politique
par les collectivités territoriales
de même l'article 9 inclut la montée en
débit dans les dépenses éligibles au
fonds d'aménagement numérique du
territoire la fnt cet article pour ce
d'autant moins de difficultés que la
montée en débit et déjà éligibles aux
aides du programme national très haut
débit
en revanche l'article 10 est plus
problématique il crée un droit pour les
collectivités territoriales à intervenir
dans les zones rentables
personne ne conteste la possibilité
juridique
l'autorité de la concurrence dans son
avis du 19 janvier dernier a confirmé
qu'une collectivité territoriale pouvait
intervenir en zones rentables
toutefois dans ce cas il ne peut y avoir
des dettes publiques ni de la
collectivité ni du gouvernement sur ces
zones
en outre déployé un réseau d'initiative
publique dans les zones rentables et
porter notre sens d'un fort risque
économique
d'abord cela revient à dupliquer
inutilement des réseaux publics et
privés à mettre en péril l'équilibré
économique du réseau d'initiative
publique
car lorsque les opérateurs privés ont le
choix ils préfèrent systématiquement se
raccorder au réseau privé plutôt qu'aux
réseaux publics
bref c'est juridiquement possible mais à
notre sens ça n'est pas économiquement
judicieux l'articulation entre
investissements publics et privés prévus
dans le programme national très haut
débit vise à protéger des réseaux
d'initiative publique en leur évitant de
faire de mauvais choix économiques
le gouvernement demande aux
collectivités territoriales de se
concentrer sur les zones où il y en a
réellement besoin
les zones donc les plus isolées ou
l'appétence des français pour le très
haut débit est en même temps ou si et
légitimement la plus forte c'est la
meilleure solution pour couvrir les
citoyens situés en zone rurale et c'est
à notre avis la meilleure solution pour
économiser et bien utiliser l'argent
public
contrairement à ce qui a pu être dit ici
ou là sur la péréquation le fait que les
opérateurs couvre la majorité de la
population diminue le besoin d'argent
public
je prends un exemple en auvergne les
déploiements des opérateurs permettent
une baisse de 20% de l'investissement
public
ce n'est pas le gouvernement qui le dit
c'est le conseil régional de l'auvergne
le programme national très haut débit
fonctionnent et nous bénéficions déjà de
ses premières retombées
donne des chiffres très précis 4
millions 700 mille foyers couverts en
très haut débit par le câble soit 20% de
la population un million trois cent
cinquante mille foyers raccordés à la
fibre optique ce qui représente 4 % de
la population
j'ai rencontré les dirigeants de france
télécom j'imagine que vous l'avez fait
aussi pour moi c'était le 10 janvier
dernier ils se sont engagés à doubler le
rythme de déploiement en 2012 huit cent
mille logements seront ainsi équipés
cette année il faut y ajouter 200 mille
logements neufs qui seront équipés par
les promoteurs et les projets d'auvergne
et de la manche qui ont été soutenues je
le disais tout à l'heure par le
gouvernement c'est une belle
accélération une réelle accélération du
rythme de déploiement
s'agissant du haut débit vous savez 100
% des français y ont accès par l'adsl ou
par le satellite
la france est le troisième pays européen
en termes de pénétration de l'internet
haut débit
devant l'allemagne la suède et le
royaume uni c'est je crois remarquable
et c'est le résultat d'une régulation
avisé qui a incité les opérateurs à
investir dans leurs propres réseaux
plutôt que de louer le réseau de france
télécom
j'en viens aux articles 11 et 12 qui
crée un régime de sanctions pour les
opérateurs en retard sur leur
déploiement
je veux vous alerter sur cette
proposition et vous dire très
franchement que je la crois dangereuse
rien n'oblige aujourd'hui des opérateurs
à déployer des réseaux de fibre optique
instaurer de nouvelles pénalités pour
les opérateurs qui déploient de la fibre
optique va avoir ce nous l'effet inverse
à celui que vous recherchez au lieu
d'inciter les opérateurs à déployer le
réseau
elle pourrait très bien les en dissuader
par prudence
aujourd'hui 95% des lignes installées en
fibre optique dans notre pays ont été
déployés par les opérateurs privés
vouloir dissuader les investissements
privés
qui ont déployé la quasi totalité des
lignes de très haut débit serait selon
le gouvernement une erreur rappelez-vous
s'il fallait rappeler quelques exemples
l'échec du plan câble ou du minitel qui
n'était ni ouvert à la concurrence ni à
l'innovation
or c'est précisément l'ouverture à la
concurrence et une régulation avisés qui
ont permis l'essor de l'internet haut
débit en france
mais au delà de la france partout dans
le monde dans les pays qui ont réussi
par ailleurs une fois qu'on a dissuadé
l'investissement privé sont bien l'état
et les collectivités qui se retrouve
confronté au mur d'investissements la
question à ce moment là se pose comment
financer les 24 milliards d'euros
d'investissements publics
vous savez comme moi que c'est
incompatible avec l'état actuel est très
vraisemblablement futur à court et moyen
terme de nos finances publiques
autrement dit l'ensemble du cadre
politique financier et réglementaire est
aujourd'hui en place pour le déploiement
du très haut débit en france alors qu'on
veut non et je sais que ça a suscité un
certain nombre d'impatience voire
d'agacement
convenons que sa mise en place a été
longue elle a duré presque quatre ans
entre l'adoption de la loi de
modernisation de l'économie et le
lancement effectif du programme national
très haut débit
je sais que certains d'entre vous on ne
trouvait que ce délai était long mais en
même temps et il est vrai même arrivé de
de trouver et de le ressentir
mais en même temps essayons de prendre
ensemble un peu de recul et réalisons
ensemble que c'est probablement un
chantier sans précédent
souvenons nous ensemble que le téléphone
avait été déployé en france en un siècle
par un opérateur public en situation de
monopole
nous sommes en train de remplacer
l'intégralité de cette boucle locale par
de la fibre optique en à peine 15 ans et
avec la participation de quatre
opérateurs nationaux et de dizaines
d'opérateurs locaux
je veux vraiment vous alerter sur ce
point cette proposition de loi revient à
modifier le cadre financier et
réglementaire mis en place par le
gouvernement et par l'arcep
cela revient à réengager un nouveau
processus de discussions ne vous leurrez
pas de ne pas de plusieurs semaines ou
de plusieurs mois mais deux plusieurs
années les investissements seront
mécaniquement à nouveau gelé comme il
l'avait été en 2008
entre 2008 et 2010 en attendant que les
règles soient clairement fixé ce n'est
me semble-t-il d'intérêt ni de notre
économie ni de nos territoires
il ya aujourd'hui deux types de
collectivités
celles qui ont décidé d'avancer leur
concitoyen bénéficieront les premiers du
très haut débit et une minorité de
collectivités qui semblent contester
encore les règles dans notre pays s'est
doté ce sont malheureusement les
citoyens habitant ces territoires qui en
subissent et en subiront les
conséquences
j'en appelle donc au sens de l'intérêt
général
l'ensemble du cadre politique financier
et réglementaire est aujourd'hui en
place des collectivités et les
opérateurs avancent et fournissent le
très haut débit aux français les
premiers chiffres sont encourageants et
nous devons poursuivre nos efforts afin
que la france entre dans le plein de
plain pied dans l'ère du très haut débit
cette proposition de loi nous confronte
à un choix soit nous bloquons à nouveau
le déploiement du très haut débit pour
plusieurs années soit nous continuons
d'avancer
afin de fournir le très haut débit à
tous les français je vous remercie
merci la parole est hervé maurey
rapporteur de la ppl
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
essayer pas être trop long que j'imagine
qu'il ya beaucoup de mes collègues qui
souhaitent intervenir
je rappellerai comme vous les faits
monsieur le président que cette
proposition de loi qui a été déposé par
mon collègue l'euro et moi-même fait
suite au rapport qui a été adopté par la
commission juillet à l'unanimité donc se
dire que l'unanimité de la commission
s'est retrouvé dans les constats que
nous avons dressé et les propositions
que nous avons formulées sur les sur les
constats malheureusement mais c'est pas
la première fois je ne partage pas
l'optimisme du ministre sur sur le haut
débit j'entendais le ministre dira
l'autre jour que 100% de nos concitoyens
avaient accès au haut débit
je crois qu'on est nombreux dans cette
salle à pouvoir dire l'inversé être prêt
monsieur le ministre à vous inviter sur
nos territoires vous constaterez que
malheureusement il y a encore quantité
d'élus qui aimerait simplement avoir du
512 kilobits secondes
vous disiez vous même lors d'une
précédente audition qu en dessous de 2
mégas en avait pas aujourd'hui un débit
satisfaisant et même les chiffres
officiels indiquent que 77 % de la
population seulement a accès à cette
connexion à 2 mégabits seconde
j'indique d'ailleurs que selon un récent
rapport publié par nos collègues députés
même de la raudière et ma mère l on est
dans la moyenne basse de l' ocde en
termes de débit puisque les connexions
moyennes sont à 3 mégas sur territoire
français alors que la moyenne de la cdc
entre 3 et 6 donc sur ce point là on
voit que les choses ne sont pas aussi
satisfaisante que que vous l'évoquez sur
la téléphonie mobile
c'est la même chose et je me réjouis que
comme vous l'aviez d'ailleurs déjà
signalé vous soyez prêt à ce qu'on
revoie la manière dont on mesure la
couverture du territoire en téléphonie
mobile parce que si on a aujourd'hui des
chiffres qui peuvent là aussi paraître
satisfaisant
on sait bien que c'est parce que le
thermomètre n'est pas fiable et que l'on
prend en compte uniquement la réception
de la téléphonie mobile
le en dehors des habitations en position
immobile et et en zone est en zone
habitée donc ça aussi on sait que ce
n'est pas satisfaisant sur le sur le
très haut débit sans reprendre ce qui
était peut-être une boutade mais avec un
fond de vérité les propos de la fnccr
qui disait qu'au rythme où nous allions
il faudrait s'entend pour couvrir le
territoire
je ne partage malheureusement pas votre
votre optimisme
on a un système alors vous voulez vous
voulez laisser à penser qu'en fait on
serait hostile au fait que les
opérateurs privés puissent déployer
c'est pas du tout simple on est hostile
au fait qu'il y ait une relation
totalement totalement déséquilibrée
entre les opérateurs privés et les
collectivités locales c'est ça le
problème est ici même à votre place il
ya quelques jours le président de
l'autorité de la concurrence faisait
remarquer que c'était même contraires à
la concurrence ce système actuel qui
permet à un opérateur de geler le
déploiement d'une collectivité
simplement en disant qu'il ira sur un
territoire et c'est ça le fond du
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans cette relation totalement
déséquilibré où les opérateurs font ce
qu'ils veulent quand ils veulent où ils
veulent alors comme cette entreprise
privée je les emblèmes pas qu'elle ait
les opérateurs vont uniquement ou c'est
rentable donc elle laisse aux
collectivités les zones qui ne sont pas
rentables et les collectivités doivent
pédaler dans deux zones non rentables
avec avec des concours de l'état dont la
pérennité très aléatoire puisque comme
vous le savez le fonds d'aménagement
numérique du territoire est toujours pas
et toujours pas alimentés et donc c'est
cette situation qui est qui est
extrêmement préoccupante c'est ce
déséquilibre qui existe entre le pouls
la toute-puissance disons des opérateurs
et des collectivités qui ne peuvent même
pas si elle le souhaite aller sur la
totalité de leur territoire pour essayer
de trouver au moins une péréquation
économique
alors c'est à partir de ce constat et
justement on ne voulant pas
revenir totalement sur le modèle choisi
par le gouvernement parce que on aurait
pu on renie à penser dire le modèle
choisi est pas le bon modèle il y à
d'autres modèles qui ont été mis en
place dans d'autres pays
prenons un de ses modèles par exemple -
à titre personnel je trouvais que que le
système des sociétés d'économie mixte
qui a fonctionné en france pour les
sociétés d'autoroutes aurait pu
fonctionner chez chez nous on n'a pas
proposé ça pour ne pas perdre du temps
et pour ne pas casser ce qui est engagé
l'objectif de cette proposition de loi
tout en disant il faudra quand même voir
au bout de trois ans comment ça
fonctionne c'est d'améliorer le
dispositif actuel est pas de le casser
donc améliorer le dispositif actuel
c'est justement faire en sorte que l'on
sorte de ce déséquilibre qui existe au
profit des opérateurs que l'on fasse en
sorte que quand un opérateur dit qu'il
ira quelque part ce ne soient pas
simplement des paroles ce soit des
engagements écrits et contractuels et
c'est pour cela que l'on veut renforcer
le rôle des schémas d'aménagement
numérique des territoires que l'on veut
l'ailé les élargir à l'ensemble la
problématique numérique parce que c'est
vrai que sur certains territoires
l'urgence c'est peut-être pas le très
haut débit peut être que sur ces
territoires là s'il y avait déjà un
véritable haut débit ce serait une bonne
chose et c'est pour ça qu'on aborde
aussi la question du véritable haut
débit sur d'autres territoires et fera
peut-être mettre l'accent sur une
meilleure couverture à moi court terme
de en téléphonie parce que quand vous
nous parler de la couverture 4g qui sera
satisfaisante vous le dites vous même
c'est dans quinze ans donc on peut pas
dire à des élus ou à des citoyens
patientez votre téléphone il
fonctionnera formidablement bien dans 15
ans donc c'est pas possible
donc c'est pour ça que ces schémas
d'aménagement numérique des territoires
on veut qu'ils couvrent l'ensemble la
problématique numérique
on veut que ce qui est dedans est une
valeur contractuelle et on veut ça nous
paraît normal qu'un engagement qui n'est
pas tenue ils soient sanctionnés je veux
dire cccc la base d'une relation
contractuelle
surtout lorsqu'elle est lourd pour la
collectivité puisque elle gêne elle gèle
pardon son sa propre action
on veut que 6,7 cet engagement n'est pas
tenue eh bien il soit il ya une sanction
pour pour non respect des engagements
voilà la philosophie de cette
proposition doit je veux pas être trop
long et est entré dans tous les
dispositifs mais l'essentiel se situe
dans ce que dans ce que j'ai indiqué
j'ajouterai quand même que vous en avez
parlé mais assez rapidement on a eu
quand même le très très très très
intéressant avis de l'autorité de la
concurrence que nous a présenté ici même
le président il ya moins d'une semaine
et j'allais dire que l'on retrouve dans
cet avis nombre de remarques que nous
avons pu formulées dans le rapport et
dans la proposition doit il est
notamment indiqué dans ce dans ce
document dans cet avis que l'opérateur
historique n'a aucun intérêt à déployer
la fibre
compte tenu de la rente sur le cuivre
dont il bénéficie c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est l'autorité de la concurrence
il est dit aussi que les pouvoirs
publics devraient exiger des opérateurs
je cite la plus grande précision dans
leurs intentions de déploiement et
veiller de manière régulière à leur
strict respect et il est également
indiqué qu'il faudra éventuellement que
le gouvernement envisage si nécessaire
sérieusement de revoir en profondeur la
logique de de son plan et le toujours
toujours cet avis souligne que le choix
qu'a fait le gouvernement est un choix
d'opportunité à ce qui est tout à fait
son droit naturellement mais si
l'autorité souligne que c'est un choix
d'opportunité cela montre bien contrario
contrairement à ce que certains ont pu
vouloir nous faire croire au nom des
règles européennes que d'autres choix
était était possible et puis
et puis chose aussi très important
puisque c'est pour cette raison qu'on
avait saisi l'autorité de la concurrence
l'autorité de la concurrence reconnaît
tout à fait aux collectivités la
possibilité de couvrir l'ensemble de son
territoire dans le cadre d'un si haut
j'ai donc voilà ce que je voulais dire
pour ne pas être trop long on aura bien
sûr l'occasion d'en reparler
le 14 février mais cette proposition de
loi je crois qu'elles répondent de
manière très pragmatique aux réalités de
terrain que les élus rencontrent encore
une fois je crois que c'est pas un
hasard si cette si le rapport avait été
adoptée à l'unanimité de la commission
et si l'ensemble des élus ou plutôt des
associations 2 et d'élus que j'ai
rencontrés se retrouvent dans cette
proposition de loi
merci monsieur murray est ce que vous
avez évoqué rappel des discussions que
nous avons eues avec monsieur lasserre
concernant tous les cas les
manifestations d'intérêt parce que il
s'agit simplement d'une déclaration et
qu'il serait sans doute plus intéressant
monsieur le ministre
qu'on ait un périmètre clair un
échéancier et pour non-respect des
pénalités c'est que ça bloque les
initiatives de projets intégrés donc là
je m'arrêterai là mais c'est pour
rappeler ce qu'on a discuté avec le
président de l'autorité de la
concurrence déjà il ya huit jours
monsieur michel teston merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
n'évoquerai pas les aspects téléphonie
mobile et haut débit qu'hervé morin a
longuement évoqué je me contenterai de
d'aborder la question du très haut débit
à la fois
s'agissant je le ferai enfin mon
intervention de la desserte satellitaire
mais plus généralement sur le plan
national très haut débit qui a été
arrêté par le gouvernement il y à
quelques quelques mois ce qu'on peut
dire et je confirme en tous points ce
que dit hervé c'est à dire que ce plan
fait la part belle très belle aux
opérateurs privés qui ont le champ
complètement libre dans l'âge
une tendance dans les zones dans la zone
2 les zones moyennement denses et qui
fait en sorte aussi que qu'ils n'ont pas
participé à l'équipement dans la zone 3
qui est réservé aux collectivités est
entendue toutefois qu'elles ne peuvent
pas arriver a assuré la péréquation en
matière d'investissements sur leur
territoire parce que le gouvernement est
seulement le gouvernement a décidé que
si elle est internée dans les zones
moyennement denses et ne pourrait pas
être aidé pour les zones très peu denses
ce qui me paraît absolument anormal
comme les aide pas pour les autres
moyens demandant si elle décide
d'intervenir soit mais au moins qu'on
les aide pour les zones peu denses comme
on le ferait si elle se contentait
d'intervenir sur ce territoire là alors
un mot aussi sur cette question c'est
que un mot complémentaire pendant cette
question comme sioniste qu'il faut que
le gouvernement revienne sur cette
partie du plan national très haut débit
en acceptant effectivement d'accompagner
les collectivités territoriales qui
veulent faire de la péréquation ça
m'emmène puisque je parle d'intervention
du gouvernement a posé la question de
l'intervention financière du
gouvernement
c'est peu investi dans le passé pour la
téléphonie mobile 44 millions d'euros
total de mémoire sur plusieurs années ce
qui est pas beaucoup sur le haut débit
s'est guère investi et si dans le grand
emprunt il ya 4 5 milliards d'euros à la
fois pour les investissements et pour
les services on est bien loin
effectivement des moyens qu'il faudrait
mettre en oeuvre pour développer le très
haut débit
donc il me semble pour le moins
nécessaire que le gouvernement s'engage
dans le fonds d'aménagement numérique du
territoire par un abonnement au fur et à
mesure que les projets des collectivités
vont être présentés un mot sur l'offre
satellitaire dans reçu récemment lors
d'une audition le représentant de telles
stats et je voudrais un peu corrigé les
chiffres que vous avez donnée parce que
le satellite ka sat est dimensionné
actuellement pour desservir trois cent
mille ménages
or d'après les statistiques de l'arcep
il y a six cent mille ménages
qui n'ont pas accès aux 512 kilobits par
seconde et par ailleurs tout le monde
connaît les problèmes d'asymétrie avec
les satellites dans le tarif le plus bas
de cassatt à 29 euros
il ya 6 mégas certain réception mais il
n'ya qu'un méga en liaison montante et
si on veut avoir 4 méga en liaison
montante et 10 en réception le tarif
passe à 99 euros
donc je crois que là aussi cela prouve
qu'il est grand temps qu'on puisse
s'engager très fortement dans un
partenariat plus équilibré entre les
investissements privés et publics pour
développer le très haut débit sur notre
territoire et le gouvernement n'en prend
pas le chemin
merci les paroles et abreu de retailleau
bien monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président je pense que cette proposition
de loi
finalement elle a de bonnes intentions
il ya de bonnes idées
il ya un certain nombre de modalités par
contre avec lesquels je ne suis pas
d'accord et je veux le dire librement je
suis un élu comme vous tous élu local
j'ai en charge 11 dames il m'est arrivé
de direct bea eric besson ce que je
pensais on s'est opposé donc je
revendique ma liberté vis-à-vis des uns
et des autres ce qui paraît peut-être
lorsque il ya un certain nombre de
textes de dire les choses vraiment comme
je les pense les les bonnes intentions
c'est évident dès qu'on est des cons en
charge un territoire
l'outil le levier numérique il paraît
essentiel et la carte pro de la
prospérité en france elle est en train
de se dessiner
et même dans le monde donc c'est un
levier dont on a besoin et tous les élus
aujourd'hui ce qui n'était pas être le
cas je me souviens il ya quelques années
tous les élus désormais partage ce
consensus c'est très bien le deuxième
point il ya aussi de bonnes idées
je trouve je reviendrai mais on en parle
très peu souvent le rapport sur la
tarification pour les entreprises c'est
quelque chose d'important en huit jours
qu'il ya des offres de fibre pour les
entreprises oui mais à quel tarif
notamment pour les petites entreprises
et ça ça n'a pratiquement jamais été
abordés je pense est important que la
ppl laborde donner plus de vigueur aux
dan
en les rendant un peu un peu
contraignant vis-à-vis des collectivités
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut assumer ce comment dirais-je ce
risque politique et dire aux
collectivités bougez-vous ainsi dan
c'est un outil de pilotage de stratégie
il faut le faire c'est trop important
les enjeux sont sont fondamentaux de
même que rendre éligible comme l'est le
fsn le fsn est éligible à la montée pour
la montée en débit donc moi ça me paraît
normal de transposer j'étais rapporteur
de la loi du 17 décembre dit pintât on
l'avait ont sans doute oublié peut-être
en tout cas on l'avait réclamé à
l'époque et rendre éligible pour la
montée en débit le fan c'est très bien
et c'est logique
là où je suis là où les modalités je
pense me semble parfois les beaucoup
trop loin c'est que d'abord je moi je
pense que sur le numérique quelque chose
qui est un secteur qui exige énormément
d'investissement où on a mis énormément
de temps à définir un cadre je pense
comme montesquieu qu'il faut toucher la
loi d'une main tremblante
je pense très franchement qu'on arrive à
un moment donné on a bien vu que les
opérateurs privés ont eu les accords
tous les accords enfin tous les zappeurs
les opérateurs privés ont désormais des
accords de coinvestissement c'est bien
bon parce que ça me permettra de ne pas
gaspiller d'argent en revanche moi je
pense qu' un certain nombre de modalités
du texte peuvent remettre en cause le
cadre tel qu'il a été défini et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
à ce moment précis ça n'est pas
raisonnable de le faire les
investisseurs vous savez que les
actionnaires de ces grands opérateurs
n'aime pas la fibre
pourquoi n'est-il pas la fibre tout
simplement parce que la fibre c'est un
investissement de long terme qui
rapportera sur le long terme et on sait
très bien que les actionnaires ont une
vision un peu myope des choses bien donc
si demain si demain nous envoyons des
signaux propres à remettre en cause un
cadre qu'il a fallu plus de quatre ans
et j'étais aussi à l'époque je m'étais
impliqué sur la sur la lme j'ai suivi ce
cadre à toutes les étapes et je vous
assure qu'on en a bavé
je suis prêt à développer les choses eh
bien je pense qu'on risque de
déstabiliser d'autant plus que
on prévoit des sanctions franche et y
compris des taxes moi je pense que
l'action aujourd'hui prévoit une
sanction aujourd'hui prévoir des taxes
dès aujourd'hui il l'est faudra demain
sans doute on est loin d'avoir consommé
les 900 millions d'euros du fsn très
bien je pense qu'il y en a pour deux ans
pour les consommer on a du temps pour
cible et l'assiette et les taux sur les
taxes qui devront alimenter le fan il
faudra le faire mais aujourd'hui il faut
que l'investissement prenne son envol et
l'investissement sera ralentie
si on remet en cause le cadre
règlementaire et si on dit aux
opérateurs on va prévoir des sanctions
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à ce
que l'on puisse créer je pense que le
cadre créé un modèle plutôt coopératif
entre les collectivités et les
opérateurs
si aujourd'hui on graver dans le marbre
une forme de conflit avec des sanctions
à la clé
alors on est sur notre coup et on est
sûr du résultat
très franchement je le dis comme je le
pense
en revanche je le dis à hervé et à
philippe leroy moi je pense qu'on peut
néanmoins avoir trouvé des modalités qui
renforce sa coopération moi je suis
d'accord que pour les manifestations
d'intentions
il faut un suivi je l'appelle
longitudinal parce que si et je pense
que la sanction c'est quoi si la remise
dans le périmètre public c'est la remise
en périmètre public du du périmètre sur
lesquels a porté la manifestation
d'attention c'est ça la sanction c'est
ça la sanction c'est pas une sanction
financière
d'ailleurs cette solution financière
j'attends j'attends que l'arcep qui n'a
pas d'ailleurs autorité pour le faire
aujourd'hui
ou que n'importe quel gouvernement
agisse et prennent véritablement des
sanctions dissuasives
mes chers collègues donc en plus quand
une sanction on l'a prévoit il faut
qu'elles puissent être appliquées donc
je pense que il ya des moyens de mieux
suivre les appels les manifestations
d'attention il ya des moyens
peut-être aussi sur la téléphonie mobile
et d'autres sujets d'avoir peut-être et
avec des dates
je crois qu'on en a un petit peu marre
des programmes de zones blanches zones
grises il ya peut-être une des deux ladd
a à mettre pour faire en sorte que l'on
se mobilise et que en règle un certain
nombre de choses
en revanche si demain je vois sur
l'article
le jeu suivi comme vous le savez avec la
commission du dividende numérique les
attributions de 4g si on vient juste ya
un mois on a ya un mois attribués le
ministre lui rappelait c'est ses
licences bon si demain on trouve à
nouveau thermomètre pour que le nouveau
thermomètre change les obligations des
opérateurs
c'est compliqué donc moi je suis très
favorable à ce que le groupe de travail
travail c'est clair c'est d'ailleurs sa
dénomination mais je crois que on peut
il faut qu'on sorte par le haut sans
casser les équilibres qu'on a mis des
années à établir et que d'autres voisins
européens nous envie et je pense que
enfin il faut que l'on sorte aussi par
le haut il ya des moyens de faire je
ferai des propositions et j'espère que
l'on trouvera cette voie qui nous
permettra d'associer le public au privé
certainement pas l'opposé parce que et
je connais des collectivités j'ai en
tête des départements qui ont financé
des dizaines de milliers de prises moins
de 4000 sont reliés aucun grand
opérateur national n'a souhaité aller
sur le territoire ok merci je pense
qu'on va s'arrêter sur ce premier ses
trois premières prises de parole qui
concerne d'ailleurs les trois j'allais
dire plus branché mais de nos collègues
et trois spécialistes
non juste une petite remarque quand même
à me bruno retailleau je connais son
travail sur le dividende numérique mais
elle sanctionne que vous évoquez
monsieur leur rapporteur de ce dividende
me paraît quand même un peu léger
ça veut dire que pendant des années
avant de constater la carence la seule
sanction serait d'avoir bloqué pendant
quatre ans ou 5 ans l'initiative de
projets intégrés donc ça me paraît un
peu là j'ai comme pénalités ou comme
sanction peu importe qui aura la parole
tout à l'heure monsieur nuit
bien merci monsieur le président
beaucoup de choses ont été dites par le
rapporteur dans mon introduction
j'avais répondu je crois par
anticipation un certain nombre de
remarques faites donc je ne je ne les
reprend pas sur l'optimisme
d'abord être optimiste n'est pas un
défaut en soi dans la circonstance c'est
à la fois de la lucidité
si je regarde les les chiffres et du
volontarisme eux au regard de ce que
nous mettons en oeuvre remarque plus
plus ponctuelle sans 100% de nos
concitoyens ont accès à internet haut
débit
ça suscite des réactions de votre part
alors peut-être qu'on peut dire
potentiellement accès ça veut dire
qu'ils peuvent s'ils le souhaitent
puisque trois offres à ses pardons trois
offres satellitaires de service
universel existent pour un tarif que
nous avons voulu et que nous avons
demandé limité à 35 euros par mois
équipements de réception compris ces
offres sont accessibles depuis n'importe
quel point du territoire
donc il y à bien en matière d'internet
haut débit un accès potentiel de 100 %
de nos concitoyens sur le très haut
débit
vous citez la fnccr qui qui dit vous la
cité à ce rythme il faudra un siècle
pour déployer 100 % du territoire
je crois avoir montré que non
c'était bien sûr d'ici à 2025 que nous
entendons le faire mais je veux dire
surtout que le programme national très
haut débit commence juste à être mises
en oeuvre avec les cinq premiers
départements les années 2009 2010
2011 ont été bruno retailleau l'évoquer
il ya un instant des années de montage
administratif au cours desquelles les
opérateurs ont gelé les déploiements si
nous modifions de nouveau le cadre
juridique les déploiements seront de
nouveau gelé
vous n'avez pas de possibilité de faire
autrement
sur les engagements des déploiements des
opérateurs puisque vous êtes les uns et
les autres intervenus ces engagements
portent bien désormais une champions
celle qu évoqué bruno retailleau à
l'instant qui est le basculement de la
zone dans le réseau d'initiative
publique
en cas de non respect de l'engagement et
ses engagements ne sont pas monsieur le
président est vérifiée au bout de quatre
ans ils le sont chaque année ils le
seront chaque année nous nous y sommes
engagés et nous le mettons en oeuvre de
façon transparente
il y a donc à la fois comme vous le
souhaitez un périmètre claire et un
échéancier
ce qui veut dire que monsieur le
rapporteur que vous ne pouvez pas dire
et les opérateurs peuvent déployer les
réseaux où ils veulent et quand ils
veulent ils ont été interrogés
ils ont détaillé par écrit leurs
intentions de déploiement année par
année et commune par commune ses
intentions ont été mises par écrit dans
le cadre de conventions signées
localement avec les collectivités
territoriales donc il ya bien un
périmètre un échéancier et une sanction
dernière remarque sur l'autorité de la
concurrence
la vie que vous citez est que l'autorité
vial de rands est effectivement
intéressant parce qu'il fixe les
conditions respectées par les
collectivités locales dont le lancement
est dans la mise en oeuvre des réseaux
d'initiative publique
mais cet avis ne remplace pas il est
complémentaire
il s'ajoute à la vie que l'autorité
avait rendu le 17 mars 2010
approuvant le programme national très
haut débit et il s'agit aussi d'un avis
complémentaire de la décision de la
commission européenne du 19 octobre 2011
c'est donc récent qui a validé notre
programme concernant les questions on
remarque de du sénateur michel teston
est d'abord sur le le fonds
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
et là aussi bruno retailleau dans son
intervention a évoqué quelques points
auquel je souscris d'abord le
gouvernement a mobilisé vous le savez
900 millions d'euros des investissements
d'avenir pour accompagner les projets
des collectivités
ces crédits permettront de financer des
projets pendant plusieurs années
une fois ces 900 millions d'euros
engagés l'état abondera le fonds pour
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
c'est très clairement l'une de nos
priorités
mais au-delà de ces 900 millions d'euros
le besoin de financement public restent
à préciser
nous avons lancé une étude pour essayer
d'évaluer précisément le besoin de
financement public au vu du coût
constaté sur les premiers déploiements
et je suggère d'attendre les résultats
de cette étude avant de décider sur la
source d'alimentation à terme du fnt
pourquoi décidez alors même que nous
avons ces 900 millions qui sont
disponibles dans lesquelles nous allons
puiser progressivement pourquoi décider
d'ores et déjà d'un montant d'une
assiette que nous n'avons pas dont nous
n'avons pas encore de l'évaluation sur
la péréquation
parce que vous y êtes revenu et que je
voudrais que les choses soient très
claires entre nous sur le sujet le
programme national très haut débit
incite les réseaux d'initiatives s'ils
souhaitent bénéficier d'un soutien à se
concentrer sur les zones de carence de
l'initiative privée
pourquoi pourquoi avons nous choisi cela
deux pour deux raisons d'abord il faut
assurer la sécurité juridique des
investissements
consenti la commission européenne et
l'autorité de la concurrence
on peut on bien précisé qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir des aides d'état ou plus
exactement qu'il peut y avoir d'êtres
d'état que dans les zones non rentables
donc ça il s'agit c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure dans mon introduction on
n'interdit pas mais on ne peut pas
bénéficier des aides
donc c'est un élément très important
donc le dire la paire est que pourquoi
ce système de péréquation scène ça
permet d'abord enfin pourquoi ce que
cette concentration sur les zones de de
carence à permet d'assurer la sécurité
juridique d'abord deuxièmement il s'agit
d'éviter les situations de superposition
de deux réseaux sur un même territoire
avec le risque c'est est évoquée par
bruno retailleau que certains ne soient
pas utilisés en tout état de cause ce
serait une dépense inutile et ça
remettrait mécaniquement en cause le
lait qui livre le modèle économique du
réseau d'initiative publique
il nous semble au contraire je veux
irait insisté que se concentrer sur les
zones de carence de l'investissement
privé présente deux avantages d'abord
que le projet bénéficiera de la
péréquation organisé par le programme
national très haut débit puisque cette
péréquation
elle existe l'aide varie en de 33 à 45 %
elle est conclue comprise entre 33 et 45
% suivant le niveau 2 entre guillemets
ruralité du département deuxièmement les
lignes de fibre optique dans les zones
rurales sur les plus chers à déployer et
en même temps et vous ne dites
constamment ce sont celles dans les
français ont le plus besoin et c'est
donc en zone rurale que l'adsl est le
moins performant
l'appétence des foyers ruraux pour la
fibre optique va compenser le coût plus
élevé de ces prises bruno retailleau a
dit plus plusieurs choses avec
lesquelles j'étais d'accord y compris le
rappel historique de points de désaccord
le la ppl propose à un rapport sur la
tarification des accès très haut débit
pour les entreprises et donc de ce point
de vue là je partage le point de vue de
bruno retailleau sur l'utilité du
rapport initial et sur des objectifs qui
sont assignés de même rendre obligatoire
l'élaboration des schémas directeurs
je les dis dans mon introduction c'est
sans doute une bonne idée j'ai
simplement dit vous êtes mieux que placé
pour le savoir qu'elle est degré
d'acceptation potentiel des
collectivités taurian territoriales mais
le gouvernement n'a aucune réserve de de
principe sur les sujets sur les
sanctions
je paraphrase est ce qu a dit bruno
retailleau à mon sens il là il a bien
souligné
au fond il serait paradoxal de punir les
opérateurs qui décident d'investir
parce que c'est à ça que qu on
aboutirait et il ne faut pas en la
circonstance au regard du mur
d'investissements de du montant
d'investissements à réaliser
il ne faut pas donner le sentiment qu'on
oppose publics et privés mais au
contraire qu'on les rangs
complémentaires dans l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens je partage aussi la
conviction du du sénateur retailleau sur
le fait que cette complémentarité est la
clé de la réussite pour déployer la
fibre optique
honnêtement qui peut croire dans cette
salle dans dans ce bel hémicycle dans
lequel il intervient pour la première
fois donc je veux saluer la la
conception et la modernité
merci qui pourrait croire qu'un monopole
public aurait les moyens d'investir
seuls les 25 milliards d'euros
nécessaires personne ne peut le croire
et qui peut on aurait imaginé que
l'investissement privé on ait intérêt à
le dissuader
deuxièmement en cas de carence
initiative privée jeu je le redis c'est
bien le rôle de l'investissement public
de se révéler complémentaires et c'est
pour ça que nous avons mobilisé des 900
millions prélevés sur les
investissements de d'avenir que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
merci je pense qu'il ya une question qui
va intéresser mayotte si j'ai bien
compris je sois il y tout à fait
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre effectivement je souhaite
attirer votre attention et vous
interroger par rapport aux cas de
mayotte 101e département où résident
deux cent mille français et où nous
battons le record du monde du débit le
plus bas puisque il est à 50 54 et
hobbit
inutile de vous dire que cela n'arrange
pas la situation déjà préoccupante
actuel de mayotte saint plus de parler
de communication et bien ça freine tout
simplement
le développement économique de l'île
monsieur le président la république qui
s'était déplacé à mayotte en janvier
2010 avait déclaré avait promis que nous
aurions le haut débit avant la fin de
l'année 2011
au jour d'aujourd'hui nous attendons
toujours
j'ai moi même saisi madame la ministre
de l'outre-mer d'une question écrite
pour lui demander quelle était la
prochaine échéance pour qu'enfin sur ce
sujet sensible
et manifestement simple les mahorais et
enfin les mêmes droits que le reste de
leurs compatriotes donc au jour
d'aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de réponse
peut-être que vous vous en avez une
le ministre à l'heure où nos voisins du
continent africain sont équipés du très
haut débit
mayotte a toujours le débit le plus bas
le choix qui a été arrêté par un le
gouvernement et par ailleurs celui du
duo débit de la d2 la dsl est ce que ce
choix vous paraît pertinent alors que
vous même vous dites que il faut passer
au très haut débit aujourd'hui et alors
que nos voisins je le répète nos voisins
de l'afrique continentale sont
aujourd'hui au très haut débit
merci la parole est à pierre est récent
merci monsieur le président le ministre
croit qu' on est sur un sujet où il ne
pas se passe pas un jour une semaine ou
un jour sans que on est l'occasion de
rencontrer ça veut dire que le sujet
d'importance ça veut dire aussi que s'il
ya eu unanimité sur le rapport c'est que
croit tout le monde peut comprendre
qu'il ya une demande non satisfaite qui
a un véritable besoin d'aménagement du
territoire qui a une impatience et une
attente avec un calendrier qui donne
l'impression pour certains secteurs qui
est très très loin
je rappelle que dans cette maison il ya
en 1996 avec bruno sido quelques autres
lorsque nous avons commencé à discuter
ici de textes sur les télécoms 2000
peut-être enfin pour moi 96 donc ça
commence à dater
un de vos prédécesseurs monsieur le
ministre avait dit ce qui va se passer
en matière d'évolutions technologiques
des communications électroniques mais à
l'époque on disait encore telecom et
c'est à peu près dans les 15 ans qui
viennent
c'est à peu près la même chose que ce
qui s'est passé entre gutenberg et
l'imprimerie de d'aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire quatre cent cinquante ans
d'un côté et 15 ans de l'autre
mais l'évolution sera aussi
spectaculaire aussi rapide quand on
regarde en matière de techniques de
technologie on a un peu oublié en route
aux bénéficiaires de la solution la plus
fiable c'est que par la publicité qui
est faite par les opérateurs eux mêmes
que ce soit les opérateurs de contenus
ou les opérateurs de réseaux on pourrait
d'une manière un peu simple dire en
dehors de la fibre optique pas de salut
alors à partir de ce moment là il ya une
logique quelque part à ce que dès lors
que nous sommes sous la pression
c'est que on essaye d'avoir la meilleure
couverture possible par le
la solution de la fibre optique
néanmoins vous l'avez rappelé vous même
on parle de 24 milliards d'euros ce qui
est quand même quelque chose de
considérable
parallèlement à ces en a des obligations
qui sont faites aux opérateurs qui sont
concernés et puis on a des avis qui ne
sont données par des experts par l'arcep
par l'autorité de la concurrence et on
voit bien apparaître que rien n'est
interdit que les réseaux d'initiative
publique et les collectivités qui
subissent la pression au quotidien de
l'électeur du citoyens électeurs
contribuables ont une priorité c'est
d'être desservi le plus rapidement
possible donc à partir du moment où on a
dit ces choses là il me semble que je
prendrais qui a dit bruno retailleau
pour dire que la complémentarité me
paraît être la solution la plus efficace
pour avancer vaut-il encore qu'on en
fixe le cadre et pour qu'un n'est pas un
des deux en permanence qui soit à la
traîne et d'un côté comme de l'autre
parce qu'on peut être dans un dialogue
de sourds ou la collectivité dit c'est
pas à moi de payer
on a d'autres collectivités qui disent
on voudrait payer mais on peut pas on
n'a pas le droit ou si on le fait on
prend un risque considérable jeudi je
répète toutes les fois parce que je
pense je le dirai tout le temps c'est ce
qu'a dit monsieur la série à peu près
six mois
il a dit vous pouvez faire des réseaux
tant que vous voulez monsieur silicani a
repris la même formule ya pas très
longtemps en dise on peut réaliser vous
avez la liberté de faire tous les
réseaux que vous voulez mais j'attire
votre attention
c'est que en l'état actuel dès textes
européens ou des textes nationaux
vous n'avez les seuls qui peuvent
utiliser les réseaux pour réaliser ce
sont les opérateurs et seulement les
opérateurs
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'en
termes de business plans de montage
économique de financement des réseaux
les seuls clients possibles sont les
opérateurs à partir de ce moment là ça a
été dit tout à l'heure on peut on voir
apparaître des prises réalisées des
réseaux de fibre optique qui sont
aujourd'hui la fibre noire et que
personne veut activer alors j'y reste
pas jusqu'à dire qu'il peut y avoir des
ententes
sur j'allais dire la non-intervention
sur ces choses là mais il faut qu'on
arrive quelque part il faut qu'on arrive
quelque part à écrire que dès lors que
on a joué on joue la complémentarité de
on a un schéma et qu'on a quelque part
que ce soit une convention un ppp des
services publics toutes formes
juridiques permettant l'objectif numéro
un c'est de desservir leur a plu le plus
rapidement possible l'objectif de 100%
du territoire en n'oubliant pas non plus
la complémentarité des solutions
techniques qui sont le cuivre la fibre
optique et les complémentarités
satellite et non pas le palliatif
satellite je crois que dans certains
secteurs et en particulier en zone de
montagne dans jonah relief
il ya des secteurs qui seront j'allais
dire pour très longtemps desservi pour
ceux qui le veulent bien
pas par le satellite donc crois qu'on a
besoin dès lors que le schéma est arrêté
que les contrats sont passés c'est que
l'article 20 du contrat c'est que celui
qui est l'opérateur ou les opérateurs
qui peuvent utiliser les réseaux dès
lors qu'ils ont arrêté le schéma est
qu'ils en sont quelque part
concessionnaires ils s'engagent à
utiliser de manière formelle est
obligatoire la totalité des réseaux qui
sont mis à disposition dans le schéma ça
on a besoin de l'écrire quelque part
alors ça peut être le contraint ça peut
être la convention mais ça peut être
aussi le pouvoir législatif qui dit le
principe de ces choses là je crois que
c'est quelque chose d'important
enfin juste deux mots sur la couverture
de la téléphonie mobile
parce que on y revient régulièrement
je crois que depuis l'origine nous
sommes dans un calcul qui est aux
à-côtés complètement de la réalité de
quoi s'agit-il
ça veut dire qu'on donne des
pourcentages de couverture des
populations en matière de couverture de
téléphonie mobile alors que par
définition elles sont mobiles et que la
population est fixé sédentaires donc 3
continue à dire 96% de la population
couverte en téléphonie mobile sur un
territoire donné n'a pas de sens puisque
la téléphonie mobile ce qui importe
c'est de savoir le pourcentage du
territoire qui est couvert et pas de la
population du territoire
ça vaut pour la téléphonie fixe ça vaut
pour internet ça vaut pour tous les
modes fixe mais la téléphonie mobile ce
qui nous intéresse est en tout point du
tellement vrai que dans les pays qui ont
vu arriver les télécommunications je
termine là dessus qui n'avait pas de
réseau fixe fiable ce sont les pays
d'europe vous prenez la roumanie ou
prenez la pologne venait tous ceux qui
avaient des réseaux ou inexistants ou
insuffisant aujourd'hui ils ont une
couverture de téléphonie mobile à 100 %
du territoire partout pourquoi parce
qu'il avait pas d'autre solution
c'est comme quand vous allez aux états
unis et que vous expliquer qu'en france
le wifi ça a pas forcément très bien
fonctionné le wimax encore bien et
encore moins et on vous disait aux états
unis ça marche parce que vous avez le
choix entre le wimax wimax dont vous
êtes sûr que ça marche
merci effectivement dans les solutions
alternatives à la fibre je m'étonnais
tout à l'air de ne pas entendre parler
du wifi le monsieur le ministre
après les différentes interventions
c'est important de remarquer comme mes
collègues que c'est l'ensemble de la
commission qui a pris position sur cette
question et qui aujourd'hui
fait une proposition de loi qui est
somme toute raisonnable mais qui a un
souci essentiel c'est de faire en sorte
que la couverture numérique du
territoire soit assurée avec le haut
débit
tout simplement parce qu'on sait qu'un
territoire c'est la qualité de ses
infrastructures et bien sûr les
infrastructures on voit souvent les
routes on va souvent la voie ferrée mais
le numérique maintenant est aussi
important que ces routes et six voies
ferrées s'il n'y a pas une couverture
numérique du territoire
inévitablement cela connaîtront de
graves difficultés et tout à l'heure
vous nous disiez que on ne rend vous
parlez de 100% de couverture du
territoire
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il faudrait que
le gouvernement travaille beaucoup plus
avec les collectivités territoriales
pour connaître mieux
vous savez ce que c'est on dit toujours
le diable est dans le détail savoir que
les 100% n'existe pas que souvent des
élus locaux territoriaux sont appelés
parce qu elles sont blanches parce qu'il
ya encore des zones grises
parce que ici et là une entreprise une
exploitation agricole n'a pas internet
le haut débit internet tout simplement
une l'adsl pour justement travailler
correctement et c'est pour cela que moi
je verrais bien le débat qui a
aujourd'hui je me rappelle avoir eu un
un dialogue avec un des grands
opérateurs de téléphonie mobile et qui
s'occupe aussi du haut débit
il y avait dit écoutez monsieur le maire
nous moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
zones denses
le reste c'est votre problème c'est un
peu facile vous comprendrez bien parce
que si on laisse faire comme ça le
marché les opérateurs et si on se
partage pas le territoire y compris les
zones à faible densité et
si dans les jeux d'hier est la valeur
ajoutée gagner dans les zones denses on
en réinjectant pas un peu dans les zones
rurales et dans d'autres espaces alors
il y aura les bénéfices pour certains et
puis le service public payera le reste
et ça c'est une conception
quand même qui mérite d'être discutée
moi je préférerais qu'il y ait un plan
numérique du territoire très audacieux
où il ya les opérateurs qui prennent
leur place toute leur place dans les
besoins de danse mais les autres zones
aussi qu'il y ait les collectivités
territoriales l'état et que ce plan
numérique et un calendrier parce que le
temps presse et la deuxième chose que la
qualité de cette couverture numérique
soit vraiment la possibilité de
travailler bien sûr pour que tous nos
concitoyens est accès à ce service
mais je pense à nos entreprises monsieur
le ministre parce que c'est votre
responsabilité
je dois vous le dire ça peut éviter les
délocalisations et la
réindustrialisation ira aussi avec cette
obligation d'avoir pour les entreprises
le haut débit merci s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues qui reste quatre accords
a maintenant fois cinquième demande
d'intervention je sais que monsieur le
ministre aimerait bien qu'on termine
vers 16h mais où je demande si possible
mes chers collègues d'être un peu plus
concis que les précédents mathieu fouché
meja président fait c'est très court
parce que beaucoup de choses on est
abordée tout à l'heure sur le haut débit
notamment ce que disait monsieur irisson
convenait tout à fait sûr le très haut
débit simplement en soi téléphonie
mobile ont il ya des mesures qui ont été
mis en place est inhérent si un certain
nombre d'années il ya toujours des
problèmes en matière de téléphonie
mobile et à free qui arrive c'est vrai
bon le gouvernement à un moment donné
avait parlé de sanctions pour les
opérateurs qui ne voulait pas faire un
centre d'opérations je veux savoir
quelle est votre sentiment là-dessus et
comment vous envisagez des choses à
l'avenir monsieur ministre n'est pas
tellement monsieur le président très
bien vous devriez être contagieux
vous voulez bien sanctions contre 10 ans
mise à mort né d'un d'appliquer des
sanctions à certains opérateurs qui ne
paraisse qui ne veulent pas mettre en
place itinérance ou qui refusent
d'intervenir
donc il me reste encore trois personnes
je vous demande monsieur bailly monsieur
kamini monsieur du bout oui ça c'est ce
qu'en dit au début daniel pardon
monsieur dubois monsieur monsieur bailly
d'abord envoyé sans dire que je sois
très compétent dans ce dossier
j'interviens président c'est le ministre
et le président sans dire que je sois
très compétent dans ce dossier d'amm et
je crois qu'on le vit quand même un
petit peu sur nos territoires au
quotidien ces deux mini camps mais nous
étions beaucoup d'activistes hinx un
petit peu avec les réalités du terrain
alors je pense que je vais me tipper
gore de sentiments si pourquoi on
n'arrive pas quand même à faire une
régulation comme quand ces faits
l'électrification avec le passé et c'est
rare et moi j'aurais bien aimé que vous
précisiez si cela est possible par la
deuxième chose aussi
si réellement on n'arrive pas là est-ce
que ça n'aura pas faire quand même
l'objet je pense qu'il y aura toujours
des des contrats de plan qui viendront
entre les territoires et l'état est ce
que pour que cette péréquation ce face à
ce malaise qui vaudra pas la faire en
priorité justement pour la couverture
des territoires pour que dans le futur
contrat de plan on arrive vraiment est
là pour les territoires qui ont le plus
de difficulté où les coûts sont les plus
importants peut-être à ce moment là des
sommes beaucoup plus conséquente pour
arriver à faire en sorte que les
objectifs qu'elles ont été définies
puisse le faire et puis deux dernières
observations c'est que aussi aujourd'hui
ils font n'a pas toujours là puis quand
même des les opérateurs parce que quand
une collectivité aussi essaye d'émettre
des projets on voit souvent les
opérateurs privés qui disent malaure
attendait nous on a prévu d'apporter le
haut des airs de faire le haut débit
chez vous dans trois ans dans deux ans
alors qu'on sait que finalement séparés
elle
là aussi quand même on souffre aussi de
ses déclarations d'opérateurs qui
pratiquement viennent dire à des mères
ou à des conseillers généraux mais c'est
pas la peine de vous en occuper nous on
va le faire et c'est ça aussi quand même
que l'on rencontre sur le terrain j'ai
pas osé et ses informations il rencontre
celle merci merci monsieur le noir mon
intervention sera d'autant plus brève
que mon collègue et ami monsieur bailly
a soulevé une question pour sa ré majeur
voie sur 2 résultats
comment comment mes chers collègues
l'électrification rurale s'est faite
après la guerre grâce à la participation
des collectivités locales à travers les
syndicats intercommunaux et grâce au
financement accordé par le fasse et or
qu'est-ce que le fasse et c'est à
prélèvement sur les recettes de
lectrices et de france répartis ensuite
entre les collectivités
si nous n'arrivons pas à mettre en place
un système qui fasse que les opérateurs
d'une façon ou d'une autre
n'apporte pas une contribution
collectivités car de toute façon des
collectivités vont participer
j'appartiens à un territoire rural si on
veut avoir le très haut débit
il faut que nous payons mais je ne vois
pas pourquoi nous seuls devrions payer
quand d'autres sont servis à l'avance
donc il faut un dispositif de
mutualisation et je souhaite que nous
travaillons ensemble à un tel dispositif
qui pourrait tout à fait ressembler au
passé monsieur le président j'ai répondu
à votre attente en étendue crois qu'on
peut dire c'est le tout satisfaction
mais je vous donne acte monsieur camani
oui nous l'avons tous dit l'économie
numérique est un formidable accélérateur
de croissance et les les territoires
ruraux ne veulent pas un être exclu et
le modèle économique qui est retenue qui
nous est proposé justement ne permet pas
l'aménagement équilibré du territoire et
c'est bien là le fond du problème et
tous les élus ruraux le savent bien ici
et cela viennent d'être évoqués je
pourrais évoquer mon département qui
viennent d'adopter un schéma et qui pour
obtenir le déploiement ftth
doit dépenser 400 millions d'euros dans
mon département qui fait 330 mille
habitants cinquante mille habitants
relève des investisseurs privés voyez
donc la masca jeudi 4 5 millions pour un
budget du département c'est
effectivement un investissement et
fonctionnement ses 4 5 millions d'euros
le budget annuel
notre département s'il n'y a pas de
péréquation s'il n'y a pas de
soutiennent plus importants ou de
financement de financement pérenne ne
pourra pas se doter de cette
infrastructure comme comme beaucoup
d'autres même s'il affirme la volonté
d'avancer parce qu'encore une fois c'est
un élément de compétitivité dont nous ne
pouvons pas nous passer et notamment les
territoires ruraux c'est pour cela qu
effectivement la mise en place d'un plan
numérique d'une d'un plan fin d'un
schéma plus contraints globalement et
qui associe à la fois les investisseurs
privé et le public est la solution qu'il
faut mettre en place rapidement
merci monsieur daniel dubois ont
peut-être deux mots par oui monsieur
bruno retailleau que j'ai vu réagir tout
à l'heure mais tissu est passé pas
nécessaire donc le match est passé
aurait ok monsieur daniel dubois
merci monsieur le ministre doit
justement
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
cinq dossiers a priori de financement
qu'avait d'aidé déposée sur donc des
zidane à prouver est ce qu'il est
possible d'avoir viré les partenaires
financiers locaux
est ce que toutes les régions
participent tous les départements oui
mais je pose la question parce que j'ai
aussi je la pose c'est pas elle sait que
j' y ait de raison
toutes les régions pas légalement et
ensuite éventuellement les com de com si
elles sont organisés en syndicats
donc je voulais savoir effectivement si
toutes les collectivités on va dire
majeur enfin son partenaire de ses
financements
j'ai bien compris ce qu'il ya derrière
non mais le après la ppl sur échasses je
ne suis plus un perdreau de l'année et
donc monsieur le ministre vous avez
salle la parole pour conclure cette
audition merci merci pour la question
posée par le sénateur soilih alors
probablement qu'il faudra que je réponde
plus précisément mais de trois éléments
indicatif d'abord il ya une première
solution c'est le haut débit par
satellite et cette solution elle elle
est d'ores et déjà disponible pour ce
qui concerne la fibre et l'adsl c'est
plus compliqué techniquement on y
travaille et la meilleure façon d'y
travailler c'est de préparer la liaison
sous marine qui est indispensable alors
il faut relier mayotte vous le savez
avec un câble sous marin
c'est le préalable indispensable au
désenclavement numérique du territoire
grâce à la loi de développement
économique de l'outre-mer
l'état peut accorder un avantage fiscal
aux opérateurs qui investissent dans ces
câbles sous marins
les discussions sur la défiscalisation
sont en cours avec mêmes elles sont en
cours de finalisation avec france
télécom
afin d'accélérer son projet le
déploiement devrait avoir lieu dans les
semaines qui suivront cet agrément
fiscal
donc je comprends ce que vous dites sur
le rythme
nous avançons réellement concernant ce
qu'a dit pierre hérisson jeu bon je
souscris à plusieurs de ses propos je
veux relever le soutien qu'il a apporté
aux principes du programme national très
haut débit
c'est à dire à cette complémentarité
entre initiatives privées et initiatives
publiques elle est d'autant plus
importante que ce sont comme pierre
hérisson a dit les opérateurs qui vont
in fine et utiliser les réseaux et
commercialiser les services aux clients
donc elle est indispensable
deuxièmement l'élaboration des schémas
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
décrivant les zones relevant de les
initiatives privées et les zones
relevant de l'initiative publique comme
vous l'avez dit et troisièmement le
respect des engagements pris par les
opérateurs privés comme ceux des
collectivités publiques
je veux redire que la avec la sanction
du non respect des engagements privé le
basculement de la zone concernée dans le
périmètre de l'initiative publique
je leur dis parce que je n'ai pas
toujours le sentiment d'être entendu que
c'est une sanction que les opérateurs
considèrent comme importante et qui me
paraît plus importante que d'autres plus
aléatoire qu'on a cité enfin sur la
téléphonie mobile j'ai bien entendu les
les les remarques
le groupe de travail que que je citais
tout à l'heure qui est prêt qui va être
officiellement installée le 8 février
s'en saisira et on va essayer de
d'avancer ensemble sur deux sur le sujet
c
l'ambition oui bon jeu j'y reviendrai
peut-être tout à l'heure bon ne bougez
pas je suis maman on équipe voudrait que
je sois encore plus précis que que je ne
le suis mais le temps passant je réduis
mes ambitions
n'y voyez rien d'autre que la référence
à l'audition de cet après-midi pour ce
qui concerne les remarques de martial
bourquin
il y a un implant numérique du
territoire en cours d'élaboration
75 départements et régions ont déjà
élaboré leur schéma d'aménagement
numérique du territoire ça répond en
même temps à la question que vous m'avez
posé ma conviction c'est que ce plan
numérique du territoire doit être
élaboré de manière décentralisée en
prenant en compte l'ensemble de des
schémas locaux pour ce qui concerne le
la complémentarité nécessaire
est ce que vous avez dit de ce que doit
être la préoccupation de l'état du
gouvernement relative à l'aménagement du
numérique du territoire
je pense et bruno retailleau rappelé le
rôle qu'il a joué
je veux redire devant vous que ce que
nous avons fait ensemble avec le
parlement c'est quand même quelque chose
exceptionnelle
ça n'est pas moi je n'étais pas en
charge qui parlait à l'époque de
fréquences en or pour les fréquences
issues de l'extinction de la télévision
analogique et nous avons fixé
je veux le redire des critères
d'aménagement du territoire
ça ne s'est jamais fait en france je ne
connais pas d'autres pays qui est
assignée à ces opérateurs
des contraintes d'aménagement du
territoire
je me souviens même et certains parmi
vous doivent s'en souvenir que lorsque
nous avons fixé les critères
d'attribution des licences dites 4g hees
a suscité un peu de scepticisme parfois
j'avais dit les trois critères ces
aménagements du territoire concurrence
et valorisation du patrimoine immatériel
de l'état et certains disait à juste
titre nous nous posions nous mêmes la
question
ces trois objectifs sont ils réellement
complémentaire est conciliable
n'allez-vous pas en sacrifier un à
l'arrivée nous n'avons rien sacrifier il
y à bien une exigence d'amérique
d'aménagement du territoire comme il n'a
jamais été fait la concurrence va être
réel tous les opérateurs vont intervenir
quant à la discussion sur dans ces
conditions le prix de réserve
n'est-il pas trop élevé l'histoire
maintenant et faites le film et est
achevée et l'état va récupérer pour ces
fréquences en or et je trouve bien qu'il
en soit ainsi parce que elles sont
exceptionnelles dans dans la qualité il
faut bien valoriser le patrimoine
immatériel de l'état
l'état va récupérer plus d'argent plus
d'un milliard que ce que par rapport à
ce que nous avions escompté est ce que
vous aviez voté au budget donc je veux
redire à martial bourquin à quel point
le fait que la france pour ce qui va
être l'accès à internet à haut et très
haut débit mobile est choisie est
imposée parce qu'il faut appeler les
choses par leur nom que ce soit déployée
en même temps dans les villes et dans
les campagnes
à quel point ça rejoint la préoccupation
que vous avez exprimées et qui rejoint
celle de nombreux deux de vos collègues
pour ce qui concerne je vais très vite
puisque alain fouché a évoqué des
questions quel j'ai répondu que pour ses
collègues pour ce qui concerne la
question
précise des sanctions le gouvernement à
doter l'arcep de pouvoir de sanction
contre les opérateurs qui ne respectent
pas leurs obligations de couverture du
territoire
donc c'est à l'arcep elle dispose d des
outils si si elle le souhaite et le et
le pan ce utile de le faire pour ce qui
concerne la la question de gérard bailly
je crois que le le programme national
très haut débit organise une péréquation
efficace puisque je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure mais je veux le redire parce
qu'on n'a pas toujours en mémoire le
niveau de subventions varient suivant le
niveau de ruralité entre entre
guillemets c'est à dire selon que le
secteur est plus ou moins rural elle
varie de façon assez importante puisque
elle peut être de 33 entre 33 et 45 du
besoin de financement global
je reviendrai dans dans un instant s'il
devient la question de jean claude
lenoir parce que je vais j'ai posé une
une question sur à mon équipe sur sa
comparaison avec le fasse et pour ce qui
concerne l'intervention de monsieur
camani comment comment garantir que des
opérateurs tiendront leur leurs
engagements de déploiement
d'abord il ya deux outils de de biais il
faut les
deux actions plus exactement que de bien
les inciter à investir
cela passe par un cadre réglementaire et
fiscal stable sans nouvelles taxes ni
nouvelle pénalité
les opérateurs sont prêts à couvrir j'ai
dit tout à l'heure
57 % de la population française en ftth
fibre to the home comme on dit en
français sans aucun financement public
deuxièmement mettre par écrit ces
engagements des opérateurs et prévoir
une riposte une menace entre larmes et
adapté en cas de retard au niveau
national nous avons recueilli de 31
janvier 2011 des intentions de
déploiement des opérateurs et je dédie
nous veillerons tous les ans à ce que
les engagements soient respectés et donc
application pratique ça n'est pas
reportée
c'était au 1er février 2012 dans
quelques jours donc que nous allons
vérifier ce que ce qu'ont été les
déploiements
je dois vous dire que j'anticipe sur le
fait qu' un certain nombre d'entre eux
sont en retard on en tirera toutes les
conséquences
conformément à ce que je vous ai indiqué
à plusieurs reprises cet après midi et
que j'avais des déjà dit précédemment
concernant le l'intervention de daniel
dubois sur l'auvergne l'ensemble des
collectivités participent au financement
y compris conseil régional et
départements sur la manche dans la
manche c'est le conseil général qui
porte le projet avec le soutien des
fonds européens et de l'état j'ai une
fiche détaillée sur ses projets si vous
l'a souhaité soit elle peut être jointe
aux comptes-rendus soit je pouvais là je
peux vous la remettre en main propre sur
la je crois avoir répondu à tout le
monde sauf à jean claude lenoir c'est
bien ça il est
qu'on connaît bien sûr toujours les les
plus maltraitées tu le sais bien c'est
une loi universelle
vous le savez bien monsieur sénateur
pendant la comparaison entre le des
plats
le déploiement du réseau électrique et
celui de de la fibre optique
elle apparaît séduisante mais nous
considère que c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose et c'est pour ça que j'ai
demandé un complément le réseau
électrique par d'une source de
production pour descendre pour aller
vers la distribution locale
c'est un réseau centralisé le réseau
numérique lui est par essence par
construction totalement décentralisé le
réseau électrique est en situation de
monopole légal
les réseaux de distribution électrique
sur la propriété des collectivités
locales c'est c'est la loi les réseaux
numériques eux peuvent être publics ou
privés et ils peuvent être la propriété
de d'entreprises privées ou ou de
collectivités locales alors le l'idée
d'une taxe prélevée sur chaque mètre de
déploiement pour financer un fonds de
péréquation et inopérantes dans le dans
le cas de la fibre optique est donc le
fasse et ne nous paraît pas duplicable à
internet haut débit
voilà je beaucoup d estime pour jean
claude lenoir il me pardonnera
exceptionnellement c'est très
exceptionnel de ne pas être d'accord
avec lui monsieur le président puisque
ça va être mais mes derniers mots je
veux dans un hack dans un langage qui
peut peut-être ne paraîtra un peu
abscons pour certains mais il ya
beaucoup de branches et pour reprendre
votre expression de départ je veux
saluer le l'initiative de public sénat
et de et de senna direct de d'un live
tweet comme on dit 'de de tweets en
direct de de cette audition
c'est une
je crois une belle initiative qu'il faut
saluer le sujet n'était pas des plus
faciles reconnaissons-le pour pour un
live tweet comme on dit mais ils ont le
mérite de de le faire et je crois
comprendre que c'est déjà très commentée
je veux saluer cette initiative est
demandée par le truchement de ce micro à
pouvoir saluer et serrer la main de ceux
qui ont dû abîmer leurs doigts pour
faire ce live tweet merci monsieur le
président voilà donc pour cette audition
d'eric besson devant la commission de
l'économie sur l'aménagement numérique
du territoire français une audition qui
a été enregistrée mercredi
ici au sénat merci beaucoup de l'avoir
suivi sur notre antenne ce matin très
bonne journée à tous sur public sénat